joining us now is the director of the
Hamburg Institute of International
Economics Thomas Tulpa what's your
advice to kids put the money in the
piggy bank or spend it on toys I did
this is a very difficult question
because we cannot learn from the past it
is not a good advice to look what we
have done when we were young to learn
what they now should do definitely they
have probably to save even more than we
had because they do not count on the
interest rate so they have to really do
it on their own for all their purposes
wishes the needs for the future and so I
think this is a very tough situation and
yet they have probably to search for
alternatives to the saving accounts one
alternative for adults at least is
insurance policies they usually pay what
two and a half percent but how long can
they ensures keep that up that's a very
good question because in time in a
period of so low interest rate that's
very demanding promise they did to
really say that we get all this
expectation expected returns so they
have also to search for other
alternatives and probably they have to
take more risks by investing this money
for a longer period briefly what are
some of the alternatives I'm probably
infrastructure what is a quite the new
phenomena for a long-term investments
but also raw materials and also of
course shares because they may probably
give you the best expectations for the
future back to the topic of easy money
banks having it easy with the central
bank with the european central bank
customers haven't had it easy though
when they go into miners with their bank
accounts that means what eleven percent
that they have to pay isn't that an
obscene difference in a way yes but on
the other hand the banks they have to
search for liquidity and everybody also
is keeping the liquidity because they do
not trust each other so somehow the
transmission channels are
damaged and so I think it is not fair
just to blame the banks of course also
the states they profit because the debt
burden for the public coffers is quite
lowering mr. scalper will return to you
in a moment first of all the story
you